hey guys it sounds like I'm just staying
welcome to the new YouTube layouts
I wanted to show them to you because
they're not available to everyone and
I'm not sure if all of you guys can see
them yet so before I do I want to go
through the years of my past YouTube
channel layouts and designs and it's
crazy how much YouTube has changed over
the past couple of years I've had a
channel since 2006 and an internet time
that is a freaking eternity
[Music]
okay hi welcome to my computer this is
what I'm using as a microphone and this
is my desktop screen I'm gonna show you
guys what the YouTube layout is all
about I'm gonna take you through as if
you were logged in now we're gonna go to
my channel which will take you straight
to your channel so this is the new
layout you have these little icons I'm
like pointing like you can actually see
you can see my mouse so you have these
little icons up here which you can
change to be whatever you want this is
an unsubscribed trailer so if you
haven't made a video as a welcome to
your channel so right now I just have
one of my recent videos you can go in
and choose a video I'm still figuring
this all out as we go as you'll notice
you have new icons up here but you kind
of may want to sort of tie in with your
header which I did but what's cool is as
you do this the whole thing goes with it
bothers me though was there's a lot of
white space over here so this is what I
actually uploaded the full image of my
header because what I think is one of
the cool things is the entire profile is
made so that it will be able to be
viewed on any device iPad iPhone TV so
you kind of have to make it really
freakin big but kind of made it hard
designing because really if you're
viewing on the web or on mobile you're
only gonna see a little chunk which is
right here here they now have edit links
section so you'll see that you're able
to put icon links to social networks and
the custom links whatever the first link
is that you put whether it's a second
youtube channel or website right here so
here's what it looks like to the public
as you're logged in as you'll see this
is my unsubscribe trailer which I
actually need to make a new one and here
are my recent uploads here's some
playlists and here's popular uploads now
what's cool is you're able to change all
of that so you can pretty much put
whatever you want you can change it into
a horizontal
[Music]
look at that as beautiful likes that on
there I mean I can seriously put
whatever I want another thing which may
be a little confusing at first I'm still
trying to get used to it does they have
tags now for everything so if I want to
feature a playlist of ask IJ so any time
I've ever tagged anything ask IJ this
will just populate an entire playlist
off of those results so here's the tags
so it's kind of crazy because these are
all my tags and shows you how many
things are actually tagged that's now
from tags you can actually tag playlists
so you can feature playlists so I went
to tag on about Y North Carolina and
London so I go into tag I just seen
travel feature my so that applies that
to those playlists I know it's a little
confusing but once you get the hang of
it it's pretty useful fine tag
have you seen travel feature list since
it's only four so for me this is kind of
cool because I have so many channels and
I might want to feature that stuff on my
main channel so let me show you my
gaming channel be much done and then
also I did a vlogging channel which is
the other iJustine channel so this is
what somebody who was subscribed would
see if they came to my channel that's
you guys I'm not sure about this what to
watch because I don't really want a new
ready to watch this video I don't know
how this has a million views but it's
not my favorite video I mean this is
seriously a two minute 47 second video
of us going down a freakin waterslide I
haven't got around to doing my iPhone
channel or my reviews channel cuz it
definitely takes a little time and that
my friends is the new YouTube channel
pages let me know what you guys think
let me know if you have it are you able
to view people's pages yet be sure to
leave me some comments below let me know
your thoughts like it love it why make
sure you say why can't just say that you
don't like something why do you not like
it I want to know laughs but at least
I'm gonna leave you guys with some wise
words for my Justine there are some
things that you can't control in life so
you need to make the best of every
situation find a way to make the best of
it
whether you love these channels whether
you don't like these channels I want you
guys to make the best of any situation
whether it's this situation the new
channel layouts or some situation in
your life that you may not be happy with
then no matter what life throws at you
you could make the best out of any
situation and I want you guys to know
that okay
I want you guys to take that and I want
you to apply it to your life and I want
you to just be happy oh I don't like
talking about serious things so I'm
gonna go back to uh playing Call of
Duty's I'll see you later
[Music]